aus günstigen zutaten und mit
geschickten marketing macht sebastian
liga einen teuren high protein joghurt
der sieht so schön aus für eine gesunde
und eiweißreiche ernährung traut man den
aber nicht
[Musik]
sebastian liegen lässt die muskeln
spielen schließlich gehört fitness heute
zu einem gesunden lebensstil dazu
[Musik]
trainieren kann man heute an jeder ecke
sieben tage die woche 24 stunden
die lebensmittelindustrie hat dafür auch
die passenden produkte entwickelt mit
ganz viel eiweiß die muskeln sollen
erwachsene weiß ist in vielen
lebensmitteln enthalten und gilt als der
baustoff des körpers milchprodukte wie
quark oder frischkäse enthalten von
natur aus besonders sie davon
doch immer mehr molkereien bieten
inzwischen neue produkte an mit
auffälliger werbung für protein nur ein
anderes wort für eiweiß
[Musik]
auffällig ist auch ihr preis im
vergleich zu herkömmlichen
milchprodukten sind die extra protein
varianten im schnitt deutlich teurer
doch enthalten die proteinprodukte
wirklich so viel mehr weiß dass es sich
für die kunden lohnt
sebastian lege weiß für die industrie
geht die rechnung auf jeden fall auf
warum das zeigt läge in dem er selbst
eine protein quarkcreme kreiert mit viel
wasser rührt der produktentwickler eine
basis aus milchpulver stärke und
milchsäure kulturen an diese zutaten
stecken auch in fast allen protein
erzeugnissen der industrie und sind
ziemlich günstig riecht relativ neutral
neben geschmack fehlt auch noch die
nötige portion proteine denn werben darf
man damit nur wenn das eiweiß mindestens
20 prozent des gesamt mehrwertes liefert
magerquark löst das problem
er enthält von natur aus viel protein
nun gründlich nixon fertig ist mein
protein zweck gemacht aus billigsten
zutaten sebastians wareneinsatz pro 150
gramm becher gerade einmal 18 cent und
die 9,3 prozent eiweiß tragen genug zum
nährwert bei um als protein reich zu
gelten
eine ähnliche menge steckt deshalb auch
in dem protein produkten der industrie
auch wenn das auf den ersten blick nach
viel aussieht im vergleich zu
herkömmlichen milchprodukten ist der
proteingehalt nicht höher
[Musik]
quark kerniger frischkäse oder
naturjoghurt enthalten sogar oft mehr
protein kosten aber weit weniger dass
sich die überteuerten protein kreationen
trotzdem verkaufen das liegt auch an
einem anderen trick der verpackung
marketing ist alles wie es funktioniert
zeigt sebastian anhand seiner eigenen
kreation die schwarze farbe sorgt für
den look eines fitnessprodukte sportler
der begriff hai pro team klingt nach
einem wahren er stoff kick außerdem
druckt läge die protein menge des
gesamten becher auf so sieht es nach
besonders viel aus
[Musik]
in einem fitnessstudio in düsseldorf
macht sebastian denk ist was kommt
besser an seine eigenkreation in
dynamischen design oder der klassische
magerquark dessen verpackung ist der
schlicht und unauffällig der
eiweißgehalt jedoch liegt über dem des
protein produkt
fallen die tester auf den trick herein
wenn die im kühlregal stehen würden zu
welchem produkt würde zu greifen
ja gratis zu eins ganz emotional gesehen
wahrscheinlich der stadt und es wird
zudem von den dreien jahr die goldene
mitte den speisequark bis auf einen
einzigen tester greifen alle zum protein
design produkt warum ein bisschen so ja
so sind so einen trendigen tag hat dann
vielleicht ein bisschen bessere
nährwerte ich gedacht habe dass ich viel
protein ihm versprungen sebastians test
zeigt nährstoff annonce und schicke
verpackung das zieht die protein masche
zielt vor allem auf ernährungsbewusste
eine gesunde proteinreiche
nährstoffversorgung liefern aber genauso
klassische milchprodukte und man spart
dabei auch noch eine menge geld
die industrie wendet den protein trick
längst nicht nur bei milchprodukten an
auch andere lebensmittel werden mit
protein beworben
knusper knapper oder süßkram kaum etwas
bleibt von diesem trend verschont
aber mal ehrlich sind extra proteine
überhaupt nötig und nützlich für die
allgemeinbevölkerung sind besonders
proteinreiche produkte nicht notwendig
üblicherweise braucht ein erwachsener
0,5 bis 0,8 gramm eiweiß pro kilogramm
körpergewicht pro tag heißt also ein
mensch der 70 kilo wiegt sollte zwischen
35 und 50 gramm eiweiß pro tag zu sich
nehmen
das zu schaffen ist kein kunststück wie
unser beispiel zeigt ein glas milch eine
schale haferflocken eine portion müsse
eine scheibe hähnchenbrust und zwei
scheiben käse reichen aus extra
proteinprodukte sind also nicht nur
teuer sondern auch überflüssig viele
proteine wenig fett worauf achtet ihr
bei eurer ernährung sagt es uns in den
kommentaren
und wenn ihr noch mehr über euer essen
wissen wollt dann abonniert die zdf
besser esser und schaut in den nächsten
zwei clips